One challenge is that, there's a large volume of
data. Each sample, is a sound or an image
and there are many samples per second. Sometimes because
of the way data is compressed, the volume of
data that's being sent may vary over time. In
particular the data may not be set at a
constant rate. But in streaming, we want smooth playout.
So the variable volume of data can pose challenges.
Users typically have a very low tolerance
for delay variation. Once playout of a video
starts for example, you want that video
to keep playing. It's very annoying if once
you've started playing, that the video stops.
The users might have a low tolerance for
delay period. So in cases like games or
Voice over IP, delay is typically just unacceptable.
Although users can tolerate some loss. Before we get into how the network solves
these challenges. Let's talk a little bit about digitizing audio and video.